this is 74 year old albita Midori three
weeks ago she was supposedly cremated
after reportedly dying in hospital from
coronavirus but now her family's been
informed she's still very much alive and
that they have the wrong ashes this
isn't the first case of mistaken
identity in Ecuador's chaotic covin 19
episode of Guayaquil nationwide the
number of confirmed cases has doubled
baby this is not because the cases
appeared overnight but because all the
backlog tests were processed and
reported yesterday in Ecuador no one can
really say how many people have died
from Kovac 19 only the people are dying
faster than they can be properly tested
and identified a nurse who doesn't want
to be named says that in his hospital in
Y aquí he's had to pile up bodies in the
bathrooms because there's no more room
elsewhere
that's very traumatic for us imagine I
have nightmares I'm not very well
psychologically we can't do more for a
critical patient than get them a saline
solution when what they need is a
ventilator
in Brazil it's a similar case this is
the NOSSA senhora Aparecida cemetery in
manaus the Gateway to the Brazilian
Amazon even some of the grave diggers
have died after contracting the virus in
the desperate race to bury victims Luigi
Paulo just lost his mother-in-law whom
he says could not access emergency care
vdl opera a person who needed to be an
intensive care unit was in a basic
hospital bed where they didn't even have
x-rays it's a horrible film I never
expected to see this in my life
hospitals are reaching their capacity
even before the expected peak of the
pandemic malaria and yellow fever are
already widespread in this region where
communities along the Amazon River are
days away from the nearest hospital now
Manaus has the highest mortality rate
from kovat 19 in all of Brazil a
sanitary emergency that's become a
calamity you see a Newman al-jazeera